hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are gonna be talking about how
to make the GoPro audio not suck now
this one specifically is covering the
GoPro Hero 5 and the hero 6 I recently
did an unboxing of the 6 and I've been
doing some camera comparisons over the
past couple of weeks the one thing that
is the biggest complaint from me and
pretty much anyone who has a GoPro is
how awful the audio is side by side each
should be fairly the same quality our
GoPros are now filming each other now
GoPros are great for what they are if
you have perfect lighting especially
bright outdoor lighting you're gonna get
some really incredible shots and they've
been dominating that action sports
market for pretty much as long as I can
remember but the biggest complaint that
I have ever since my first GoPro the
audio is terrible and I never realized
how bad the GoPro audio is until
recently when I tested out the sony RX z
row and it may be a little bit unfair to
even compare it to the RX 0 because the
sensor that is in the RX ear it was the
same that is the art 100 mark 5
[Music]
we are zero outside right now it's
actually pretty dark out there's a
little bit of light up above me from
these flood spotlights here but the
lighting looks pretty great I'm mostly
curious to see what the audio sounds
like in comparison to the rx100 so here
rx100
we're testing out the audio to see what
it sounds like and now here is the RX
zero audio I'm not sure what's gonna be
it's gonna be better but all of that
aside the rx0 is waterproof already the
audio on the arc zero was so good that
my mind was blown and I couldn't believe
it in any small little tiny compact
camera the biggest complaint is the
audio so because I'm still trying to
make this GoPro relationship work yeah
just keep trying I just keep putting
more effort into it and this is where
we're currently at do you see what I
have done to this GoPro to try to make
it work I've looked at so many different
solutions on Amazon and this seems to be
the best setup that I could come up with
but there are so many different issues
that I was running into but first of all
let's dissect this and let me show you
what we've got going on here the number
one problem is I couldn't find a nice
housing that had a little shoe
attachment right here I needed a
microphone that was high enough because
this is so wide angle I didn't want the
microphone to be in the shot looks high
enough to me one of my favorite
microphones is the rode microphone it's
the road goal mic let me grab it this
one wouldn't work because these little
furry hairs are so low that this is
definitely in the shot I also wanted one
where I can adjust the decibels which
this one has just kind of absurd because
do I really need that this is crazy the
other issue is where are you gonna plug
this into thanks GoPro why didn't you
just make an audio no of course that
would make things way too easy instead
this is what they sell you another 50
$60 attachment it's USB see which then
plugs into here it is so heavy this is
absolutely insane this isn't this is
unacceptable to be honest with you and
yet here I am trying
yeah this is a good idea GoPro no
actually I'm mad now I'm mad making this
video this was supposed to be a nice
little helpful tip to help you guys get
better GoPro audio and now I'm just mad
anyway moving on you need this and I was
also reading reviews that you can't use
any other third-party ones that you have
to use the GoPro one I have not tested
out any third-party ones so I cannot say
from firsthand use that they do not work
but from some of the reviews that I have
seen and read a lot of people are saying
that they don't work this one didn't
work right away so I had to do the
firmware update and then I ran into
firmware updates while I was updating me
here six you know Mike's just sitting
here like man what have I done why do I
care at some point you gotta let it go
you gotta say let it go let it go I
can't have this copra anymore the one
thing of all of us is this case is
actually really cool this little shoe is
removable so you can take this off with
a screwdriver you can put it on the side
if you want to put the microphone there
or a light or whatever it is that you're
attaching to this each piece came
separate this tripod actually it was
from the Samsung 360 camera the first
edition is actually very perfect for
this scenario this bottom part oh I
think I cracked this tripod mount huh
always something guys it's at least
something this little tripod mount isn't
a gopro tripod mount it's from Amazon
basics but it works really really well
now I'm giving this GoPro a hard time
but after this whole set up it cost me
about 200 extra dollars to try to make
this thing sound good because I'm asking
myself is this worth it because when am
i realistically going to carry this
around like this and now I've completely
made it not waterproof because I had to
take a side door off of it just access
said port
anyway this USBC adapter allows you to
have a mic input there you go
I'm loving it loving it so to make sure
that you have the proper settings I
would definitely recommend testing out
some different scenarios so when you go
into the audio input there's a powered
mic there's a power bike plus so
depending upon if you have a microphone
that power to
self or if you have one that powers
through the 3.5 millimeter jack then
you're gonna need to make sure that that
proper selection is selected and let's
see the difference between having a
microphone and not having one hey guys
it's Justine how's it going all right
we're testing this out now what do you
guys think what does it sound like oh
boy so this is what it sounds like with
the microphone attachment on I'm still
questioning why I've done what I've done
but I really wanted to just you know try
to make it work and here we are and now
let's test it out without using the
microphone and here's what it sounds
like using the onboard hero 6 microphone
it basically it feel like sounds very
similar to the 5 I really couldn't hear
much difference when I was doing a
comparison between the 5 and a 6 but the
one thing that I did like about the 6 is
the image stabilization when I was
walking with this thing I was actually
quite blown away at how stable it was
that is the one factor that really made
me absolutely love this thing so all
things considered I know I've been given
GoPro a hard time but I do really like
GoPro and I keep saying this but it just
makes me so upset because they really
could have such a great camera if the
audio was a little bit better and then I
know people were like well I'm outside
doing action sports I don't need audio
but yeah what about the rest of us who
are not doing crazy action sports this
could be a much more widely marketed
camera for everyone
I took the GoPro Plus the microphone
outside to see what it sounds like in an
outdoor condition and we're here at the
beach so there's a lot of wind actually
right now as you can tell with my hair
so let's see how this microphone handles
the wind
[Applause]
now I'm testing out beagle pro audio
just on the GoPro the microphone is not
attached here's the cable that it should
be attached to there's a big difference
I already know I don't even hear it and
I already know I'm still trying to make
the GoPro work Jen I know I'm up on the
dream the dream give it up okay but
later this is beautiful
really I just wanted to show you what I
managed to do to try to make this work
and I was really impressed with how good
the audio actually did sound after I got
everything all hooked up and working so
this is the microphone that I got it's
just a basic stereo microphone I got
this on Amazon I will put a link in the
description I feel like I probably could
have gotten a much smaller one but my
concern was if it wasn't high enough
it's still gonna be in the shot so this
seemed to do the trick I feel like it's
a little bit too big maybe a little bit
lower it looks crazy I just wish this
would stay still I mean there's a lot of
things that I just wish it would do and
it doesn't well thank you guys for
watching hope you guys sort of enjoyed
this video if you didn't I'm so sorry
I just I don't know I have so many
feelings about GoPro and I guess I just
have such high hopes and then I hear
horror stories of them stealing like
people's content and they're not giving
them credit and it's like why would you
do that you guys are so cool you don't
have to do that just be nice hopefully
this was helpful if you were trying to
find out how to make your GoPro audio
not suck and if you weren't looking for
that then thanks for watching until the
end anyway we'll see you guys my next
video bye bye
[Music]